TO HANG IS PLAYING
DOWN TO ROSLOVIC.
JOHNSON IS GOING TO GET THE
SECOND ASSIST AND
FOUGHT OFF BY GUSTAVSSON.
MEYER GOAL THE
NEUTRARA SWEEP IT
AWAY FROM THAT BLUE IN?
DID THAT GO IN?
NO, THAT WAS OFF THE POST. TO C
BEHIND THE NET, GAUNCE WITH A M
OUT THERE AND MAYBE YOU GET A
BOUNCE, AND THAT BOUNCEUP,
RIGHT OVER TO KELLY., AND WE
BEAUTIFUL PASS, ELVIS MERZLIKINS
WITH NO CHAody: I THINK
>> Jeff: GREAT CALL THE JACKETS
>> Referee: PLEASE SETS TOUICK
CAME IN OFF OF THE POINT.
AND ELVIS GETS JUST ENOUGH OF IT
TO S S THE LEFT
SIDE, NORRIS TRYING TO KNOCK IT
OUT OF THE AIR,
BJORKSTRAND IN THE TZLE FIRES AD
THERE'S GUSTAVSSON.
WHAT A GREAT  HEADS-UP PLAY RIG.
STUTZLE DOWN LOW.W. FOR THE FAC
ON HIGH AND WIDE.
ROSLOVIC FOR NYQUIST
AWAY FROM STUTZLE, BACK HANDS IN
FRONT, GUSTAVSSON.
THERE'S BEAN HE'S DRILLED HE SP
UP, HE SEES SILLINGER ANDSILLIN
CROSS ICE, GAVR FRONT, SHOOTS J
HE LOOKS, HE WANTS GUSTAVSSON TO
PULL TO THE RIGHT ON THENET.
ELVIS NOT GIVING HIM MUCH TO
TO SHUFFLE ACROSS AND GO AGAINST
THE UP HEAR
HE GOES.
>> Jeff: DOWN THE LEFT SIDE,
NYQUIST SLOWING  REAL HIGH SPOTE
PICKS IT APPEAR25%.
STUTZLE WITH SPEED, HEAD DOWN
HEADADNG
FOR THE GOALTENDER, GOOD HEAD
FAKE AND A 1-0 GAME AND THEY GE